hello everyone and welcome to another
game we'll be showing from the
uh carlos and ding match four uh it's
the sixth game they're playing and it's
the blitz game so
after the two uh uh two games that we
talked about uh game one being won by
magnus and
ding retaliating in game two that
beautiful check made on f5 square uh
the next two rapid games were drawn and
the first blitz game was drawn the one
where magnus had the white piece so now
this is the last game of the blitz
section
of match four and uh if this is also a
draw then we go into armageddon
evening wins he forces another match to
see who goes uh
into the finals of the magnus crossing
chester and if magnus wins this
then he immediately goes to the final so
without further ado let's check it out
it's
again quite the game so being again with
the white pieces opens with
d4 uh sorry about
that uh opens with the d4
magnus goes knight to f6 we have c4 and
now uh not going for king's indian
defense magnus
not really enjoying what happened the
last time he tried it
goes for e6 instead so we have g3 and
d5 now striking in the center uh we have
the
catalan opening on the board bishop g2
and now bishop to b4
check we have bishop to d2 and going
back with bishop to e7
making things bishop look a bit funny on
d2 we have knight f3
uh knight f3 and now magnus castles we
have castles biting
and now c6 and here queen to c2
so just nicely developing with b6 by
magnus
preparing bishop to b7 going for more
control over the e4 square
and now knight to e5 biting making it a
bit hard to develop the
the knight here as the c6 pawn would be
hanging so bishop b7
first and now a trait in the center c
capture c
captures and rook the c one by ding now
we have knight f to d7 by magnus
offering a trade here
uh and now this position has been
reached before and every time white
played queen to c7 and the thing about
queen to c7
is that uh it's the strongest move
recommended by the engine of course
everyone plays it here
the problem is that white never won a
game playing queen to c7 so either the
game was drawn or or black one
and this is one of those cases where the
absolute best move uh
simply isn't enough so here instead of
going queen to c7 ding tries a knight
back to d3 he just avoids the trade
and doesn't offer a queen trade and it
is as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game
so let's see what happens with knight to
c6
uh magnus now develops while the valley
uh attacking the
pawn on d4 e3 ding defends it and now
rook the c8 so it's not uh not
anything special but it does look a
little bit better than
uh for black than uh having the queen on
c7 and then
yeah just controlling the the seventh
rank so here knight to c3
uh dean would very much like to win this
with the white pieces so he doesn't have
to go into armageddon
so knight a5 and now the knight is
coming to c4 and here we have queen to
d1
ding brings the queen back and now opens
up the c file for the rooks to be traded
knight c4 and
also brings the bishop back the knight
controls the defends the b2 point so
it's not a problem
uh we have knight back to b6 by magnus
and now a4 uh hoping to to bust open the
position with a5 so we have a5 by magnus
and now knight to b5 putting pressure on
the knight here and also it's a very
nice square for the knight so here we
have a trait of rooks
rook captures rook captures and now
queen to b8 magnus prefers to bring the
other rook into the game to trade off
the remaining rooks
uh with b4 by ding and now knight
to c4 so again an excellent square for
the knight also
serves as protection to the e5 pawn a5
pawn
and now b captures an a5 with b captures
and now ding strikes in the center with
a4
and there might be some tricks maybe uh
maybe sacrificing the exchange here and
picking up the a5 pawn to create a past
a4 pawn
problem is for the moment it's not
possible because it captures pawn
captures and then also the knight will
be under attack
now and so on so here we have e4 by ding
uh busting open the center
and magnus just continues with knight d
to b6
adds another defender to the knight and
he says i don't care if you trade
if you advance you could advance uh and
close the center a bit but
even though this will somewhat close up
the light square bishop he can always go
like bishop c6 offer a trade here and
it's not going to be
it's not going to be all that much for
white so instead knight a d to b6 with e
cap percent d5 and the bishop captures
magnus gladly offers a trade of of the
bishops with bishop captures e captures
and now
knights the e5 thing says either want
you to capture here
now so i can get this pawn here or maybe
i will capture a capture here and then
maybe
who knows what happens maybe i can get a
nice past the d-pawn
and here a magnus says okay also there
are some maybe some tricks
if this knife moved then maybe we can
capture here maybe this knight will not
be defending this square maybe knight
here will be an option forking the queen
and the rook
so magnus just improves the position of
the queen with queen to b7
now everything is nicely defended also
the queen guards this the queen also
defends the bishop however
this uh allows ding for a beautiful
tactic so uh feel free to pause the
video and
try to spot this tactic while i give you
a couple of seconds and uh
a little uh heads up this is only the
first of many positive videos
in this video
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
the queen here is on a very awkward
square
now and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's bishop captures
on a5
this is what being played and now the
problem is if magnus recaptures a rook
c7
and the queen has to move you just pick
up the bishop
and you you've sacrificed nothing you've
gained the past a pawn which is also
defended so here it would just be an
excellent position for dean
so instead after bishop captures an a5
magnus said all right so if this is the
problem going after the bishop i'm just
going to attack the rook
bishop the g5 and now
now what do you play here uh so now that
the bishop moved if
f4 now you no longer care you're just
gonna capture on a4
and then now you're gonna uh then you're
gonna
attack some other other pieces for
example if you go f4 you can just
capture on
a4 you could also capture on f4 first
bust open the position but uh
like if this and this then okay you've
uh
you've given up something for the moment
but uh you can still just go back
uh or rather you uh not knight captures
on a4
uh knight captures an a5 story the
microphone uh
blocked my view of the knights knight
captures on a5 and now
uh it's just a fine position for example
if you
if you capture the bishop now then the
bishop is captured but you can go queen
to
queen to e7 put some put some pressure
on everything and
it's uh it's it is a bit harder to play
but
uh nothing nothing all really happening
here
uh so you know ding tried to give up a
piece uh but magnus gave
the piece back open opened up the king's
position and the white is still better
here
but not uh not uh you know nothing
conclusive
so this would be possible here however
after this
bishop captures an a5 and carlson's
bishop to g5
not f4 by dink but rather bishop
captures on b6 he just
keeps on giving he gives up the the rook
on c1
which is not a problem because after
bishop captures on c1
we have bishop to c5 he moves the bishop
again with a threat of capturing the
rook
so rook to a8 by magnus and now before
capturing the bishop first eliminates
one more piece from the board
the captures and only now queen captures
in c1 we have
rook captures on a4 and here uh knight
to c3 just getting the knight out of
harm's way attacking the rook and
rook to a5 and here we have a position
where
the each player has four pawns but ding
has a bishop and a nice knight for a
rook
so on all accounts this should be
winning for ding
uh and and in fact is so here uh ding
needs to go uh back needs to consolidate
a little bit uh get the queen to e3 get
the bishop somewhere somewhere back
for example however ding starts pushing
right away with h4 and now this is a
problem because now
it's magnus who has the upper hand now
again
feel free to pause the video and figure
out why this is so while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on exploiting
white's back rank weaknesses
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's queen to a8
and now the thing is the queen here uh
still controls this entire diagonal and
rook to a1 is the threat not just of
winning the queen but if you move the
queen
uh it's also just rook a1 check king
moves to h2 and the rook to h1 will be
checkmate just to give you an example
for example you move the queen
check king moves and now this or queen
delivers uh checkmate on h1
so here after queen to a8 we have queen
to b2 by magnus
sorry by ding he now needs to guard
against the uh the rook
check he needs to block it with the
knight but now rook
a1 check knight to b1 and now uh
a brilliant c3 by magnus just uh
deflecting the queen of course the
knight cannot capture if the queen
captures it's again the same checkmate
so nothing really
interesting for white there so queen b3
being has to get out of the way
but now h6 magnus also realizes that he
could be having some back rank issues
and he can spend some time uh playing h6
as dink has no way to take advantage of
this so ding pushes d5
now the queen no longer controls this
diagonal but it's not a problem magnus
just goes queen to c8
he puts pressure on the bishop and now
the queen can't still keep an eye on
both the knight and the bishop uh quinta
e8 was even better
uh because it just threatens a queen to
e1 check and there's really not much uh
not much you can do about this then
you're gonna pick up the knight and it's
an easy game
uh but okay queen to c8 by magnus goes
after the bishop
and now uh what what can you do here uh
problem is if you try something like
queen to b5 to keep an eye on both both
of these
pieces then c2 is just game over the
queen also needs to keep an eye on the c
pawn so here after this queen the c8 we
have king to g2
and now comes uh queen captures on c5
there was no way to avoid this
queen captures on c3 sorry knight
captures on c3 finally getting rid of
the past pawn
but now rook back to a8 and now what
can you do here uh well now it's magnus
who's up the exchange and ding still has
a pass
deep on so maybe not all is lost yet i
think it wants to shift the knight over
to f4 to keep an eye on the pawn here
and now rook to d8 by magnus we have
knight to f4
and now while magnus could uh just get
rid of the knight with the g5 and pick
up the pawn
it could be a bit tricky both of them
are extremely low on time a few seconds
on the clock each
and here you might run into some
problems after this for example you
capture this
uh it's uh or even with the queen even
better if the queen captures with
check you just trade trade a knight f6
check picks up the rook and the white
just wins so it's not a force line but
you
have a few seconds you do not want a
crazy knight jumping around in front of
your king
so queen to d for by magnus he just
wants to shift to the
the queen to e5 bring the rook to b8
then bring the rook into the game
and you know slowly but surely uh uh win
this
so h5 now not allowing g5 as uh
uh h captures and g6 alpha song will be
uh will be the idea
queen e5 by magnus and the queen to b6
now
uh we have rook to b8 now uh challenging
ding's queen queen to c5 and now
queen to e4 with check we have king to
h3 biting
king to h2 a bit more resilient than
after king h2 you probably face rook to
b2 with some with some air pressure here
but king h3 runs into a lot of problems
because
magnus immediately goes rook to b1 now
threatening
rook to h1 of course and here ding
escapes with king to g4 which is
incredibly brave
but it loses the game uh the thing is uh
if queen the c8
checked first king h7 and now king g4
now it's uh it's a bit different uh
because uh well
it's not so clear how to how to proceed
here with black of course black is
better but how do you
how do you win this with so so few
seconds on the clock and you still have
to worry about the past pawn the knight
really
uh does a nice job defending all of
these squares around the black king
around the white king and it's not all
that clear however ding played king to
g4
first without going queen to c8 check
first but now for the final time feel
free to pause the video and to win the
game for magnus it's actually a mate in
two
so uh you know have added
so uh for those of you who spotted the
mate mating 2 congratulations
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's f5 with
check that's why queen to c8 checking h7
was important because the queen was
guarding the f5 square from there and
here without having that it just doesn't
work
uh and here uh it was uh in this
position that the ingliern resigned the
game
and with it the match uh and with it uh
the
chance to appear in the final so magnus
carlsen is the first finalist
who will face the winner of the daniel
dubo versus hikaru nakamura matchup
here we resign because it's interesting
ding didn't allow to get checkmated on
the board like magnus
he resigned uh move prior to checkmate
but i guess it's only
you know everyone knows what happens if
if king h3 or king h4 mate will follow
so there is no nothing to do here the
pawns create a wall against the white
king that's just it
uh so yeah magnus wins he's the first
finalist and we are now waiting to see
who will uh
join him nakamura or dubo as we are
going to cover some of the games
from that match as well so yeah
that's uh that's the game i do hope you
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
paula [ __ ]
lars evan almas stephen ramsey daniel
narlow and thomas connors for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
uh grand uh grand final of the magnus
calls an invitational
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day